الى اوكرانيا حيث قال مسؤول سياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
ان الاتحاد سيقدم تسهيلات ماليه لاوكرانيا
بقيمه خمسه مليارات يورو في الفتره
المقبله واضاف براق خلال اجتماعا عقده
وزراء الخارجيه الاوروبيون في كييف ان
اقوى التزام امني يمكن تقديمه هو منحها
العضويه في الاتحاد مشيرا الى ان دول
الاتحاد ستواصل دعم وتدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على مقاتلات اف 16 الامريكيه
بالتاكيد اقوى الالتزامات الامنيه التي
يمكننا تقديمها لاوكرانيا هي عضويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا اقوى التزام امني
لاوكرانيا الان اوكرانيا دوله مرشحه
للعضويه وهي تمضي الى ما ابعد من ذلك في
هذا الطريق
من جهتها قال الرئيس الاوكراني
على تقييم ايجابي من المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لبدء مفاوضات انضمامها الى الاتحاد بحلول
نهايه العام الجاريه واضاف زيلينسكي مع
بوريل الدعم الدفاعيه والمالي لاوكرانيا
والحاجه الى اعتماد عقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي المقبله ضد روسيا باسرع وقت
في موسكو قال الكريم انما وصفه بتعب الغرب
من تمويل اكياف سيزداد وسيؤدي الى تفكك
النخب السياسيه وانقسام الراي العام
الغربي اذا اوكرانيا وتعليقا على حذف بند
مساعدات اوكرانيا من الميزانيه الامريكيه
قال الكريم ان واشنطن ستظل ضالعه في
النزاع في اوكرانيا معتبرا ان وقف
المساعدات سيكون اجراءا مؤقتا